my heart is relaxed I must say I've
never had been handcuffed to anybody for
24 hours let me finish I want to go on
tick-tock
do you believe climate change is a real
problem no of course not I regret doing
this just put that phone away okay
boomer happy holidays everyone it is my
favorite time of year and as we enter
this festive season while tensions
between boomers a Millennials continue
to grow I thought what better way to try
and sow the seeds of harmony and by
handcuffing two of them together for 24
hours so for the millennia we have one
of my closest friends Nando who was a
former BuzzFeed employee very talented
producer and then for the Boomer we have
Roy Allen an actor I hired off of
Craigslist a few months ago to help me
manipulate some of my friends we're
going to Nando's right now yeah that
music means he's awake hello hello make
sure you're and get my sandals cuz I'm
not wearing shoes being handcuffed for
24 hours with a Boomer I don't think I'm
excited I actually am very hesitant and
I'm only doing this video as a favor to
you Millennials there's a stereotype
that we are entitled lazy snowflakes and
that it is sort of on us that we can't
really find financial stability like
previous generations did and I think a
lot of that is [ __ ] because we have
inherited a system that doesn't work
like it did before
I don't have any boomer friends so I'm
excited to possibly get a new friend ah
thank you for coming Roy my pleasure
or enemy it's up to him right I must say
I've never had been handcuffed to
anybody for 24 hours much less than
millennial I'm just wondering if the
person is going to I have some level of
self discipline and respect for the
moment that's all I think a lot of the
frustrations that Millennials and Gen Z
have towards baby boomers at least from
what I've seen is a lot to do with
climate change and
economic disparities that sort of are
overseen by them the issue of the
millenials is very much discussed these
days entitlement that's a problem I
think they're naive
they're constantly checking their cell
phone for messages and other hookups
perhaps I don't want to know about and I
wondered what is the cause of that and
it's quite obvious they're addicted Jen
sees even more than Millennials are
inheriting a planet that is falling in
front of our eyes and it's frustrating
and very upsetting to see the baby
boomer generation which essentially runs
government not take that as serious as
they should I don't know what aria has
planned for me in fact I hate to
consider it but what I would like to do
is to take this young millennial to a
place of worship the spiritual location
and see if they can understand and since
what's going on my friend DJ is having a
party tonight for his birthday so I hope
he likes hotboxing apartments cuz that's
what's probably gonna happen tonight
okay it's Roy opening your door hey Roy
Oh meet you very nice to meet you as
well
yes very nice to you so this is a very
friendly start absolutely to a very long
24 hours this is my tiny apartment that
I went out to a gay bar the other night
and the no I'm not I'm just saying I'm
like grabbing them because they have fun
articles
oh please judge I didn't see that this
is where I sleep every night and I think
you guys are joining me here tonight yes
are you going to join us on the balut
Lee I think it's time we get handcuffed
oh yes do you have any problem with that
yeah I do
handcuffs don't put them too tight in
this crisis I regret doing this not not
because of you just mostly because of
him well how to manage the intimate
moments though when it comes like the
bathroom or you know showering you will
have to do that together but how do we
do that with a hand we're not how we
what what do you say some previous
handcuff videos may allow people to
uncuff and use the restroom a shower
mine won't
and I just what it is Roy I believe you
had something you wanted to show
Fernando first oh yes we want to go see
the cathedral downtown Los Angeles it's
a place of worship maybe you'll feel a
little spiritual light when you go there
will this leave it up well we'll leave
it open to the spirit let's see what
happens you can see yourself a fairly
religious person for that no no no let's
do it I love I love old buildings for
them oh yeah how was that experience I
have to be honest I felt very out of
place and I was trying to keep it
together because when you were singing
the song I didn't know it what are the
things about Millennials is that there
be out there post atheism so they really
don't believe in anything except their
feelings well is that oftentimes I like
dress all our sins and griefs to bear
all our sins and griefs
i distance myself from my religions yeah
when you have let me finish I distanced
myself from religion when I was
struggling with being gay a lot of
things in religion did push me away some
of the ideals that I heard from the
Catholic religion growing up in my
experience were outdated and I know that
a lot of that is changing but as some
could say that damage was done and I did
lose some of my faith because of that
are you getting it back no no but yeah I
mean thank you for bringing me back to
the love church did you like my song my
him I don't think he liked me him no he
doesn't it was great oh thank you it was
great it was great
every time you get a text it's a shot of
dopamine are you aware that the
technology issue with Millennials is
that they get hits of dopamine with
their texts for example we're here did
together to have a conversation and
you're on the phone all the time why you
don't understand why it's because you're
getting hits of dopamine from your texts
where did you read this no no is
generally no did you ever get somebody
sent you like a text and it just says hi
did you ever get one of those now come
on I know you have please I mean it's
followed by some nails no just hi no no
I'm sure you have just admitted please
all right you know why that happens that
person that person is wanting a dopamine
hit and they have just sent out 50 highs
so then it comes back like 20 people are
stupid and say gee it's nice to hear
from you whatever and they're getting a
dopamine hit from that isn't it so you
joke no I'm serious actually yeah
there's a good way to test this just put
that phone away this would be an okay
boomer moment because I feel like it
listen if you're into somebody in the
text you'd sure or like somebody you
want to hear from but like I have a hard
time believing there are people out
there sending mass messages that just
say hi well it starts with people you
like then you get hooked on it and then
it's the message itself just giving you
a shot what you're saying in general is
not super wrong it's not crazy if it's
not super wrong put your phone away it's
it's a way here and don't get it out I
think the best thing to do to to ease
some of the tension is do a little
holiday activity I've reserved you both
tickets to go ice-skating together Oh
lovely handcuffed oh Lord
this is so dangerous I've better suit
the hell out of much meat the thing
about the ring is that there's people
around it looking inside already so then
we decided it would be best if we're
holding hands like this so that it looks
like we're helping each other
Lord are you okay I'm great
oh but I also it was like they either
think I'm with my grandpa or my sugar
daddy I'm not impressed either way
frankly oh my god this is a okay came
home after you attacked Millennials for
using their phone so much the last thing
I wanted to do was hold your hand in
that ice rink head hurts but but I
there's something finished but I do
think it brought us closer together
I'm sorry for every nasty thing I said
about your Instagram ski I'm taking it
all back good you wanna talk about my no
no no I mean I'm not gonna talk about
your dopamine's now just I'm too
dependent on you yeah
Lord as you were very kind it was keep
me from falling and I'm very much you
helped me to I was helpless holding onto
you as well
I'll tell you Aria it's gonna get a
piece of my mind I hate that man it is
the holiday season and I would love for
you both to spread some cheer so I'm
hoping that maybe you have to do some
Christmas Carol ants to a strangers if
you sing A Christmas Carol to three
different groups of strangers no Lord
I'll let you guys uncuffed for 30
minutes hello today you got the
liveliest boomer that you can find no I
haven't agreed I'm just trying to make
you seem super into this I'm trying to
assess the opportunity that's what we do
you know the boomers assess things we
make plans and then we execute it so
like you okay boomer jingle bells jingle
bells jingle all the way oh what fun it
is to ride in a one-horse open sleigh
hey I think I had a lot of fun I
particularly like the gentleman with the
joints although I didn't smell like
marijuana it was so harsh you know
wasn't sweet wait where when is not
sweet know it's messy no it smells like
what that smell like that was a joy have
you ever smoked before marijuana really
no I don't need to get you know off on
chemicals and artificial ingredients
like coffees natural those are those
weird putting peasants to work in
Colombia okay boomer is right a change
tonight so now that was saying and
everything my friend DJ is having his
birthday party like I told you so we're
at a grocery store now it's against and
DJ a millennial yes and he smokes a lot
of weed what better than show up with a
cake that says happy birthday DJ but in
Christmas colors objection okay I think
that's good is that good I don't know
can you mix it yeah yeah we'll try let's
put in there to make I guess I will need
to your home to see this is a lack of
planning in the millennial generation
it's all spontaneous and and it ends up
screwed what do you think of Millennials
well their parents told them they're
special they're not special their
parents told them anything could happen
to them not anything can happen the
parents told them it would be a happy
ending it's not gonna be a happy ending
we don't know how to turn out it got my
fingers crossed
well how do you know it's gonna be a bad
ending well how could it turn out well
under those circumstances they have very
high expectations they're gonna be - the
minute they walk in the workplace I'm
sure you've experienced that ready are
you no not at all yeah Roy you can be as
real as well you don't to feel no I'm
not acting I'm having some mentoring
really you really think that yes of
course of course it's grateful for but
we don't often say it because it hurts
people's feelings but you're asking me
what else about Millennials like what
else do you think of they have a high
sense of entitlement they don't have any
patience they're badly prepared there's
they have no sense of cause and effect
you know they don't like Trump but what
do they do they march in a vegan parade
I mean where is the connection people do
you tell me it's called voting oh you're
right you're right you're gay we agree
there what about the criticism that you
guys get for instance with climate
change that you guys don't take it
serious and don't care about it and all
I can say is that you and I are gonna
both be dead before this becomes a
serious issue so really what do you want
to do about it anyway what there's but
there's no need your rank is order you
know have you have more immediate issues
to deal with you know like getting a job
do you believe climate change is a real
problem No
of course not my heart is raising Roy
you didn't honestly you don't to play no
I'm not I'm just giving it do you
believe it's real but you don't think
it's a problem but it's not I think it's
you know it's it's so far into the
future that it's going to be as serious
but there are thinks everything now
already related to that oh it happens
all the time she never goes up and down
all the time you know that let's--we the
fact you didn't vote last time to
climate change I would say climate
change is a non-issue the fact you
didn't vote as a disaster
yeah I think people should vote how can
you possibly complain about the
government if you don't vote but what if
I did well I doubt you did what I can't
vote I'm a permanent resident see it's
just one excuse after another oh my gosh
I don't even know what to say how do you
feel about gay marriage oh yeah well
I'll tell you as a gay man my view is
that leather gousen yeah I sure al how
was it growing up gay for you well I
have to say it fortunately I worked in
an area where you know people didn't
really ask any questions in fact did you
know it know what that you were gay of
course yeah in fact I was in a committed
relationship for almost 20 years
with yes yeah over the last really say
10 or 15 years they've been a number of
developments involving the military the
workplace where you rent or buy a home
there have been a lot of positive
elements that have reduced this line
between gay and not gay which isn't it a
very positive way so people can just
enjoy being themselves which i think is
very positive yeah that's good I feel
like you might be exaggerating it right
now
but I do believe that a lot of baby
boomers feel that way and believe those
things about Millennials which things
the ones you just said about
entitlements and like yeah but at the
same time you know we cherish deeply the
Millennials they are the young geniuses
of our society and so it actually we say
all this with a lot of sadness and with
a motivation to fix it yeah well you
know I disagree with you and what you
think makes me upset but I do like you
and I do respect you
and I'll I can respect you too okay so
we finished the cake and now we're at
DJ's house you'll notice I'm wearing
something different and that's because I
use the 30 minutes that we earn singing
Christmas songs to change into this oh
thank you you asked him of a good film
here yeah open it I'm gonna introduce ro
to all our friends and get him to meet
other Millennials and see if is as spicy
and sharp when there's a lot of us in
one room no I'm not that I'm not daring
I'm not there I'm nervous you're gonna
say something crazy hello this is DJ DJ
my man happy where do we decorated this
cake yes oh we're all good thank you
thank you hi everyone this is my friend
Roy my name is Fernando all questions
you could ask him I only know like a
quarter other people here well I mean
who doesn't
yes right they're making my sandals want
to change your pockets I do want to
choose my pants so what did you think
the party riot was an excellent party
very nice host very well set up and it
was a great opportunity to meet what 30
or 40 or 50 Millennials and you got
along with them really well
well thank you yes I know how do you
feel really handled the the party he did
really good actually
I was surprised you didn't go off
yeah I heard tick-tock tick-tock
mentioned several times I thought oh I
want a try tick-tock it's enough guys
you bring your apps there I've story but
unfortunately he took the next two hours
for me to get my passport he forgot his
password I mean I have a brand forgot up
lady right there I know my ID security
question so I took two hours and I got a
new password and i download tick tock
and not only that but Maya helped us
right yeah
upload a video and to make it go viral
make it over I'm not sure what I think
of tick tock tick tock favorites or tick
tock yeah well st. we ticked off a I'm
not sure what I think of it though Roy
you actually add a couple start with a
bunch of people you talked to Christina
NME no actually you know what happened
was I was drafted into the Army right
during that period they were asking me
what is the draft how did it work and
that's the one thing we've had it better
than you guys in a generation we haven't
had a draft like that I got deferments
for college but when I went to graduate
school they canceled the deferments I
immediately became eligible for the
draft I was dropped
[Music]
even say five or ten years after my time
they had a lottery so right and so in my
case was done deal you're drafted but
then the night the next thing that keep
us a lottery so there was a chance you
wouldn't have to go oh I got anxious
thinking about the possibility of going
to war in general and I don't even have
to fight it yeah so shout-out to you for
that all the talk about Millennials
being this way that way or whatever is
it just all nonsense or do you think
it's some truth to it
yeah the sheets guys pull it down I'll
be spending the night with you guys here
so I'll get under on this end I mean
basically this is it for the video
because by the time we wake up in the
morning I'll be 8 a.m. and I'll be
officially 24 hours any final thoughts I
don't know you might agree aria but
today was like a roller coaster I think
you were trying to rattle me up more and
you were having fun with that okay two
levels the basic point was that I felt
that what is the point of talking about
anything if you're not gonna vote and so
I is true I was making an effort to
shock you from the point of view of
saying something so fundamental and to
our survival of the planet such as
global warming that who cares that is to
say who cares if you don't vote yeah and
so that I think that I vote I agree you
know what I didn't have a lot of fun
ice-skating was very scary
you don't I will say I enjoyed
decorating that cake with you actually
coming into the day I had a little bit
of anxiety the concept of being
handcuffed to a person and that could it
be any person but I'm terrible I mean
I'm so pleased that it was you fern oh
you're very agreeable and an open-minded
person so it was very easy for me to
have
all day with you along the way I might
have hit a few notes just to get a
reaction out of you
but never did I fail to appreciate you
throughout this day when you put us into
different experiences like the skating
rink for example did did you turn the
light off did you learn something or
that you expected to see when you saw us
go around the rink yeah no I honestly
just wanted a moment of fun fun you
didn't really think it would be fun to
you in my imagination I picked you guys
just skating happily like like at full
speed well you know the thing about the
skating rink first of all it forced us
to get close to each other in a
dependent way right we're definitely
yeah interdependent yeah but then we
made a couple friends who were also part
of it it's almost like life
yeah Millennials and boomers need each
other we needed it to get through that
terrible melting ice but we were
fighting along the way yeah but at the
end of the day we like each other yeah
that's right we like each other we need
each other what a privilege to carry
everything to God